and new data shows southern nevada
hospitals are dealing with more staffing
shortages especially when it comes to
nurses in the icu so what's being done
to address it oracle mana joining us now
live from sunrise hospital with the
answer orko
well denise we're told sunrise hospital
here it's one of nine local facilities
currently dealing with a shortage of icu
nurses and this has been a problem that
has plagued the whole country for years
now but experts say covid has added to
the burden
we definitely have a group of nurses who
are very tired nurses and intensive care
units across the valley are stretched
thin a new report from the nevada
hospital association shows staffing at
southern nevada hospitals has been
elevated to a warning and nine
facilities in the area are reporting
staffing shortages particularly with icu
trained personnel we're in a tough
situation sherry chavez is in charge of
all nurses at three local hospitals
sunrise southern hills and mountain view
she says all are in need of more icu
nurses adding that the pandemic has led
to higher turnover the stress of being a
healthcare provider has taken a toll
on on our folks both
emotionally and
physically so they're ramping up
recruitment and retention efforts we're
working to fill those gaps and we're
using things like
overtime specialty pay what can also
help is using residency programs to
encourage those in local nursing
colleges to join the workforce that we
partner with all the different hospital
systems in the valley to give the
students a well-rounded experience and
kind of see what opportunities do exist
in las vegas
upon their graduation the ultimate goal
is to have enough nurses to keep our
community safe it's important it's
really hard i think to put into words
how important that is
republican assemblywoman dr
robin titus says that she has introduced
legislation that will help retain nurses
ab-142 would essentially allow nurses
who came to nevada to help during the
pandemic stay here and practice here
reporting live in las vegas orca mana 8
news now
[Applause]